mindfulness isn't sort of an indulgent
rest you know it's not like deep
relaxation it's it's almost gym for the
mind so you're building that mental
muscle to be able to notice where your
mind is notice if it's helpful for you
or not and then bring it back to now we
are speaking for the second time to Dr
Julie Smith who is a clinical
psychologist and the author of the
bestselling book why has nobody told me
this before and her book and all of her
work is absolutely fantastic and really
helps break down kind of the various
mental health issues that basically
every one struggles with into an
understandable form with lots of
actionable solutions as well I think
what people are referring to is worry
right so it's that kind of I'm thinking
about things way too much I'm going
round and round in cirle it's almost
like that kind of thought washing
machine isn't it where you're just
churning it over and over in this
episode we're going to be talking about
how to manage Stress and Anxiety we talk
a lot about overthinking and we talk
about burnout and along the way we
explore emotions we explore challenging
our limiting beliefs and we explore
strategies for how you can think about
thoughts and feelings the ability to
hold thoughts and feelings at arms
length and how we can get more
perspective on whatever problems that
we're struggling with most things that
are sort of meaningful or feel like
achievements involve discomfort on the
way so if you're not willing to make
yourself feel vulnerable and
uncomfortable you kind of close a lot of
doors to yourself I think this episode
is sponsored by kajabi and they've
actually got something really valuable
for all of our Deep dive listeners now
if you haven't heard of kajabi it's
basically a platform that helps creators
diversify their revenue with courses and
membership sites and communities and
podcasts and coaching tools so it's one
of the best places for creators and
entrepreneurs to build a sustainable
business we started using kajabi earlier
this year and as soon as we started
using it we were like oh my God why
haven't we been using this product for
the last 3 years it's got everything
you'd possibly need for running an
online course or hosting an online
community or building an online coaching
business and it essentially makes it
really easy to run your entire online
business from payments to marketing
tools to analytics kajabi has everything
that we creators need all in one place
and actually you don't necessarily need
a huge audience to generate a
sustainable income a Creator on kajabi
can for example make $100,000 by
converting just $350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to a $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions every year from kajabi we're
still only paying them a couple hundred
a year and actually in their lifetime
kajabi have paid out over $6 billion do
to creators that's billion with a be and
over a thousand creators have become
millionaires through products on the
platform now back in May 2023 I did a
keynote at a kajabi in real life kajabi
Heroes Event in Austin Texas and in that
keynote I talked about the exact steps
that I used to grow my business from
zero to over 2 and a half million per
year from course Revenue alone now
people paid for the pretty expensive
tickets to watch this keynote at the kab
hero live event but as an exclusive deal
for deep dive listeners kajabi have very
kindly offered to provide the recording
of that keynote completely for free to
anyone who listens to this podcast so if
you're interested in getting completely
free access to that keynote just head
over to kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com
and that'll be linked in the show notes
in the video description as well you
just enter your email address and then
you will get the recording of that
keynote completely for free whether or
not you ever become a kajabi customer so
thank you so much to kajabi for
sponsoring this
episode this season is Once Again being
sponsored very County by trading 2 on2
now people ask me all the time for
investment advice uh because they see
that I've made money and I've made
videos talking about where I'm investing
that money the thing that Warren Buffett
and basically everyone who's sensible in
the space recommends which is to invest
in Broad stock market index funds which
you can do completely for free using
trading 212 trading to12 is a fantastic
app that lets you invest in stocks and
shares and funds in a commission-free
fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfolio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest features so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge font Trader
who's gone onto the platform and has
created a pie of Investments having done
a bunch of research and stuff and that
Pi might be like I don't know 20% Apple
20% Tesla 10% this 10% that but it
generally way more complicated than that
and you can see the performance of that
particular pie of stocks and shares and
funds and then if you want to copy that
pie into your own account you can just
copy and paste it directly in and then
you can invest any amount of money and
it will autom automatically split it
according to the allocation in the P so
if you wanted to just play around with
£1 and you were like okay that P looks
good it will split out that1 based on
the allocations of the P which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of 100 so it's literally free
money so you might as well so thank you
so much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode right so recently I've started
to think a lot about my health and
that's why I'm very excited to say that
this episode is brought to you by hu now
I've been using hu since 2017 since my
5ifth year of medical school but since
interviewing the founder Julian Hearn on
this podcast in season 1 and hearing the
origin story of hu and how it came
together hu has now become a staple part
of my life now if you haven't heard of
it hu is essentially a meal in a bottle
so each little bottle is like a shake
that has 400 calories 22 g of protein
and a good balance of carbs and fats and
fiber along with 26 different vitamins
and minerals and obviously when it comes
to health there is nothing that beats
the gold standard which is a healthy
nutritional freshly prepared meal that
has like the perfect balance of all the
things but if you lead a particularly
busy or hectic lifestyle like I
sometimes do it can be hard to make the
time in our schedules to get this
absolute gold standard Meal which is why
I personally like using hu for those
moments of my day or of my life where I
don't quite have time to cook I don't
quite have time to like try and go to
like a gourmet restaurant and sort of
get some kind of healthy meal I just
want something that covers my bases in
terms of the macros that I need and
that's pretty tasty as well the heel
ready to drink bottles come in eight
different flavors my favorite ones are
banana and salted caramel so if you find
those you should check those out and if
you're interested in trying these out
then head over to heel.com deepdive and
with your first order you'll also get a
free Shaker if you want the heel
powdered version and you'll also get a
free t-shirt and these are quite nice
t-shirts they fit very well they make
the biceps look a lot bigger so thank
you so much heel for sponsoring this
episode welcome back to the podcast
thank you having me it's been almost 2
years to the day since we recorded our
first episode and you have an age today
oh thank you so much it's the retinoids
um but your life has changed a lot in
that time yeah yes and no in some way
you know I guess um you you might or
might not relate to this cuz you're kind
of living the life um whereas for me
when I kind of started all this I
already had children and a family and
stuff so um while life has changed to a
degree it's also a lot the same you know
I'm still getting up taking the kids to
school trying to do some sense of work
within those school hours and then being
Mom again in the afternoon and kind of
and then you know working into the night
to try and create some sort of content
yeah without looking too tired yeah um
so that feels a lot the same but um you
get to do all this really exciting
interesting stuff like come and see
people like you and like have really fun
chats and um yeah doing kind of
interesting stuff so yeah so what like
i' seen you you bid on a bunch of TV
shows and stuff like the book has
absolutely exploded in like sales
numbers and it seems to consistently be
on the best set of lists and that's just
like a level of success that is really
rare in the book publishing world so
how's that kind of roller coaster been
uh it's been amazing it kind of took on
a life of its own and
um I think I look how weird is this so I
looked last week and and it was I think
it was like 70 weeks or something 70
something weeks in in the top 10 um and
yesterday I forgot to get a paper and
have a look so that is something to
think of as you're as you're about to
publish your book that you know like
something that feels huge in the
beginning and feels like it would be a
marker of success or not um later on you
kind of forget to even look because um
not that the Shine Comes off things I'm
so grateful and it's been incredible and
it still feels good to know that it's
you know getting into the hands of
people um honestly I think the most it
always sounds a bit cheesy but is true
the most satisfying moments I've had
have been speaking to individuals who've
read it and found it useful so um I
imagined that moment that you see the
book and you know the Sunday Times would
just be momentous and but that moment
ends really quickly you know it's a
matter of seconds and then it's in the
past and and it's will it be in the next
week or will it so it's always you know
you're always looking to the past or the
future it's never the right now so while
it feels good to know that it's doing
well and it's in there some of the
conversations I've had where I've done
sort of Live Events or talks and things
people queue up at the end to come and
see me and and they want to tell me
their story where they've been what's
happened to them and how it might just
be one part of the book that really
shifted something for them and just kind
of shifted their their trajectory a
little bit and and then it's then made
such a difference over time that they
you know they will PE up for an hour to
come and speak to me and say
thank you you know and those you know
those conversations are just momentous
for me and I hold on to them and um yeah
because that's I never wanted to write
the book for the for the sake of it I
wanted to do something that was helpful
and stick to the reason I'd started in
the first place so um yeah those
conversations genuinely sort of hit me
and stay with me for sure yeah wellow
yeah I think there's definitely
something there around
um you know the things that bring the
most meaning are when we
when we're in service to others whereas
I think a lot of us me included very
much so Chase like the achievement
Accolade of like oh hey hitting the best
set list but then as you said it's just
sort of a flash in the pan it's like
cool whatevers yeah but it's I I guess
kind of seeing that impact is the thing
that really really moves you yeah I
imagine that moment of you know if that
ever happened that I would be you know
just overwhelmed with theemotion and you
know dropped to the floor or what and
there would be this sort of Hollywood
moment and it just really wasn't like
that it was sort of yeah cool um because
that bit sort of out of your hands in
some ways while you can do everything
you can do um to help that is just one
marker of success you know I could I
could probably sell that many but
everyone who bought it hated it but the
fact that people come up and say thanks
I found it so helpful that I bought
three for my family at Christmas and
that's you know yes kind of thing that's
a good vibe so what what sort of stories
do you hear about the book like what
what what kind of things do people say
that make you feel yes uh um do you know
what because it's obviously a book about
mental health and tips that come from
therapy it's often people who have
really quite painful stories and it's
not it's I think I annoy the staff
actually from these events where people
will queue up to kind of come and say
hello at the end and it's not just an
average hi thanks for the book bye kind
of situation um when somebody wants to
you know it's ceed that long to say I
want to just share something with you
and it's often the deepest darkest
moments their lives that the book might
have helped them through in a very even
in a small way um you can't take two
minutes over that you've got to take
your time and and often people at these
events people are like come on we need
to get through and I'm like no you take
your time you you know these people have
um been kind enough to to you know buy
the book and and then to queue up to say
um thank you but yeah often those
stories are around being in a really
dark
place and often not knowing where to
turn as well that the reality is however
much i' would like everybody to have
access to therapy or something like it
they don't for lots of different reasons
um and and often it's those people who
haven't had access to something like
that or that it's not been enough for
them you know if you if you get your I
don't know six or 12 allotted sessions
of the NHS and then you don't have
access to anything beyond that where
else do you go and what do you do so um
sometimes it's been in addition into
something so I guess that's that's kind
of surprising to me that I I mean for me
reading something in a book can just
completely change my kind of belief or a
decision or an action and therefore
completely change my life and people
kind of joke sometimes you know I'll do
a lot of videos being like this book
changed my life because it genuinely did
because it changed something something
substantial but before you said that I I
would have thought that oh obviously
like a book can't replace like quote
real therapy um but it seems like people
are getting some value from reading a
thing and sort of is is it helping them
reframe a thought pattern or like what's
what's going on that they're finding it
so helpful even if they've tried therapy
before yeah and and you're right it
can't replace therapy and it's it's
really um an insight to some of the
things you could learn in therapy that
you could take on yourself if you kind
of practice and reflect on those things
and you know use journaling to kind of
keep learning those skills and stuff
like that um but there's still a lot to
therapy that is so much more than that
so um you know why I'd love to give
therapy to everybody it is impossible
for that to happen um but yeah it kind
of if it can help in any small way then
it's it's worth doing I think nice one
of the things that I so I was I was
flipping through this um the other day
filled out this um feeling feeling wheel
um and me and one of our team members
were doing it to be like and I was
trying to figure out like what are the
the the feelings that I felt in the last
week or so yeah um cuz I guess since
last time with the we we did the
interview one thing that I've been like
I've been I've been seeing a therapist
as well and trying to get more in touch
with my emotions and trying to sort of
feel feel feelings in the body rather
than just sort of walking around with
them in the mind and you know when
people would ask me how how do you feel
I'd be like what like that that that
sort of question I I I I still find very
hard to compute almost but then seeing
like the feelings wheel I wonder if you
can just like describe what is the
feelings wheel and like what could be
helpful about it to to people well
actually that's a really common um
experience where you know some people
are in touch with more in touch with
their thought processes so you'll ask
them what they feel and they'll say well
I'm thinking that and they're kind of
ring off the thoughts to you or you know
you'll ask them what emotion is present
and they'll say well actually I've got
butterflies in my tummy or I'm I'm
really tense and so they're more in
touch with the physical Sensations and
emotion and it's all part of the same
experience
right and um I think I mentioned the
book about it being kind of it's almost
like weaves in a basket they're all
aspects of the same experience but you
don't necessarily experience the weaves
you experience the whole basket and so
you you get this kind of sensation you
don't necessarily have words to describe
that and and when we separate it out
into you know thoughts physical
Sensations
emotions some people just don't have the
vocab
to give granularity to you know they
might have happy sad angry frustrated
but they might not have the vocab to
kind of give that any Nuance or the fine
detail that the slight difference
between the frustration you feel in a
queue to the frustration you feel um I
don't know waiting for some really um
important medical results or something
like that they're different feelings
right but but sometimes we kind of use
the same words to for different um
scenarios or feelings because we don't
have the vocab so the feelings will
can't remember the lady's name now it's
it's in
there yes that's it so um but it's
really just a way of kind of packing in
lots of different vocabulary that you
can use to describe sometimes you just
need a little prompt right you just oh
yes that's the word I'm looking for um
that really kind of resonates with you
because sometimes when you hear the word
you kind of have an understanding about
what that feels like but you wouldn't
necessarily come up with it but it's a
really important skill actually to be
able to um give words to feelings so
that your brain can kind of help you to
predict situations and and understand
them in kind of finer detail so yeah
it's really useful yeah so it's like you
know in the middle we've got like the
six six key emotions I guess or like of
anger disgust sad happy surprise fear
and then you know around around the
outside if we look at happy for example
there's optimistic and intimate peaceful
powerful accepted proud interested
joyful ecstatic amused inquisitive
important confident respect and
fulfilled and you know was I was going
through and thinking of like which of
these things have I felt in the last
week or so um and I was sort of when I
when I I did this exercise a few months
ago I highlighted inspired playful
hopeful loving fulfilled respected
confident important inquisitive amused
liberated energetic eager and I was like
all of these were the happy ones but
worried was a sort of leads to anxious
which leads to fear which was
interesting to me and
I realized I did have periods of
infuriated and irritated which is sort
of a subset of frustrated which is a
subset of angry and I wouldn't have kind
of know I was like oh I guess I was sort
of anxious equals fear and like
frustrated and kind of irritated equals
angry there was something about seeing
it in the wheel that was like yeah I
didn't quite realize that I was like oh
I am feeling fear Yeah because sometimes
there's social pressure around or social
expectations around certain emotions as
well aren't there sometimes attached to
gender so you know um some people people
who um maybe for men for example who
don't feel that it's acceptable for them
to feel fear might use a very different
label like you say that that in the
wheel you can see that it is connected
to fear but they might use a different
label because it feels slightly
associated with something different um
and if or it feels more acceptable to
say out loud um and and maybe for women
that would be more around anger actually
that um lots of women wouldn't use the
word angry but they might use something
else um like fr ated or something um
that feels a bit more acceptable um bit
more kind of nicey nicy yeah what do you
think is the so well one thing I'm still
trying to I gu figure out is on the one
hand there's the view that feelings are
not facts and feelings are just you know
these Sensations that arise in the body
that the mind then gives color gives
color to and you know if you're feeling
angry it's because it's not it's not
actually that something has happened
that that has it's it's it's not a law
of physics that you should feel angry in
the moment it's a story that you're
telling yourself about how that person
shouldn't have done the thing which
makes you feel angry so that's like one
side of it which I think I drag the
Kool-Aid of that quite a lot where it's
like oh I mean feelings are just
meaningless right because I mean
feelings are not facts and I can I could
control my narrative and therefore
control my feelings then on the other
side there's the whole idea that like
actually feelings tell us something
valuable and you know we should be
mindful of our feelings but then people
will then get there's the risk that
people then get too attached to the fact
that they feel angry not realizing that
actually you could potentially
potentially change that do you get what
I'm get like I'm not quite sure what
there's there's some sort of balance
between these two extremes I think yeah
yeah because there's a sort of sense
that um you can go down the road that
okay well if my feelings aren't facts
then can I trust them at all and are
they of any particular use to me and the
answer is
yes because you know we we have to
accept that okay the brain's function is
is trying to um help help you generate
meaning from whatever's going on so it's
trying to help you understand what's
going on in your environment the demands
that are placed on you all of those
things but only has so much to go on
right it's only got so many Clues it
kind of assesses the situation from your
inner world and your biology and what's
going on and your blood pressure and
your heart rate and all those things and
makes an assessment about you know how
we're feeling but also from things that
are going on around us um but it doesn't
always have all the data and so it has
to kind of make a best guess
and it offers that up to you in in the
form of Sensations and feelings and um
so it's got a lot to say because your
brain's pretty brilliant at coming up
with assessments and sometimes those
early
feelings can be the most valuable right
when we listen to them um so I think we
have to you know listen to our emotions
as we would listen to any message and
hold it lightly you know except that
it's okay this is one Poss POS version
of this reality and that it's the first
feeling I got so I'm going to hold on to
that and I'm going to also stay open to
other perspectives or the rest of
experience and and so just because it's
not the one truth doesn't mean it has to
be completely disregarded you know there
are lots of um really valuable things
that aren't the be all and endle so it's
you know holding it as valuable but
realizing that if we if we blinker
ourselves and only look at that as the
you know possible truth we're really
restricting ourselves there and you can
really go down a hell hole in some ways
if your thoughts are distressing or
painful and that kind of
thing and I guess that's a skill that
people learn in therapy or through
reading the book and through practicing
like this ability to hold the feeling
but hold it lightly yeah and it's not
easy right I think the you know the
whole thing about mindfulness is you
know I think people get the idea with
mindfulness that it's you've got to go
and sit under a tree somewhere and you
know in barley or you know and kind of
live that life and it's very goal
orientated but actually you can live
mindfully in that way and that's often
the things that are taught in therapy
around um noticing and observing your
experience okay so I'm in this scenario
this feeling is coming over me I can
feel it you know in in this part of my
body or that part of my body and I
notice these thoughts are coming in and
I'm I'm gonna I'm G to allow that to be
here for a minute and I'm just going to
allow the next experience to wash over
me and I'm G to see how that goes so
you're not sort of grasping onto it for
dear life but you're also not pushing it
away you're kind of allowing it to be
present and when you don't either grasp
it hard or push it
away it kind of takes this natural
course and it washes over you and it
moves past you right so um those are
often the skills that are kind of taught
and I talk a lot about that kind of
thing in the book work and in my videos
and stuff where because it's quite a
difficult concept right to to grasp it's
like well what do I do how do I make it
go away then and the idea is you don't
have to make it go away if you
can be open to experience even if it's
unpleasant or negative or
uncomfortable and often when you stop
fighting against it that takes some of
the power out of it
anyway is it kind of like if you're
walking outside and it starts to rain
then you could be like oh why is it
raining it's so annoying or you could be
like well I guess it's raining cool and
not really has crib much any any more
meaning than that to it and and you can
still protect yourself from painful
feelings to a degree right so you could
choose okay I'm never going to go out
when it's raining which is probably not
going to be helpful in you living a
valued life or a life that is you know
important to you um but you could say
well I'm going to go out but I'm going
to take my umbrella and my coat and so
I'm going to do what I can to kind of
ease my way through this day so that it
doesn't completely overwhelm me
but I'm still going to go through the
rain nice so if like someone gets social
anxiety for example yeah one option is
like cool I'm just never going to be in
social situations which is probably not
a particularly helpful way of living um
but I guess the raid cut analogy is like
cool I'm going to I'm going to you know
these feelings are going to wash over me
I'm going to recognize them for what
they are their feelings going to hold
them lightly and here are some
strategies that I can use to deal with
them as they rise yeah for sure so when
I started doing um like live TV and
stuff like that I realized that if I
said no to that it would be out of fear
and that I had to practice what I preach
right so this is why I kept doing it and
kept saying yes to it and and so I had
to kind of you know do that but I I
recognized that when I felt anxious
before you know the sort of few seconds
before they say you're
live um I could put some skills in place
so that would be my you know my jacket
and my umbrella are okay I'm going to do
this because it's meaningful to me to um
hold sort of Courage as a value and and
challenge myself and push myself so I'm
living a valued life you know based on
what matters most to me and I'm just
going to take these skills along to make
it easier um so I would you know um I
will you do the sort of physiological
sigh or something a few seconds before
just brilliant really really helps um or
I'll do lots of reframing as well if I'm
tempted to you know often I wake up in
the hotel room that morning and think
why am I putting myself through this and
then immediately allow that thought to
be there but frame it and come in with
this is really exciting it's a challenge
it's really small can comparison to most
things in the world um and we'll get
through if I you know fall on the stage
and humiliate myself I'll have my end
back so you know putting all those
little things in place nobody can
physically see those things they're all
skills that happen kind of in here um
but they allow me to then do something
that is living in line with my values
love it what's a physiological s uh so
that's um just a breathing technique so
you um you take a a large in breath and
then just when you feel like your lungs
are full you takeen another small breath
and then you do a long sort of vigorous
out breath
so so it's allowing the out breath to be
longer than the in breath um and I I
talk about lots of it's just one of the
different ways to kind of do slow
breathing techniques um um but they're
all in the book what it do like what's
the the theory behind it so the idea is
you're not only you kind of slow your
heart rate down but when you take that
extra in breath that you're opening up
the little sacks in your lungs a little
bit wider so you're actually getting rid
of carbon carbon dioxide more
efficiently than you would be um so it
helps you to sort of calm the system and
honestly it you know those really small
things no one can even see you're doing
it but it makes a enough of a difference
that you bring anxiet so you're not
trying to eradicate anxiety ever yeah
you're just trying to bring it down to a
level of intensity that you can really
focus on what you're doing and and
perform at your best so yeah I wouldn't
want to be totally relaxed when I'm you
know on live TV I want to be alert and I
want to be thinking well and performing
at my best but I also don't want to be
completely overwhelmed and
catastrophizing I want to be kind of in
the zone so it just helps to you know
only a few breaths helps you to really
kind of get in the zone and then do what
you do and it's so in in that moment I
guess you could tell yourself the story
that oh my God I'm feeling some level of
anxiety and live TV I'm not cut out for
this why did I do this like uh this for
me but I guess you're like no that's
fine if t feel some level of anxiety as
long as it's not hindering my
performance too much yeah and that's
what the mindfulness stuff does really
is it changes your relationship with all
emotional experience because you're
accepting all of it the good and the bad
or the you know comfortable and
uncomfortable should I say um as just a
part of being human and it's part of The
Human Experience so you're kind of
allowing that to be there so okay when I
do this I notice those Sensations my
heart pounds just beforehand and you
know I'm tense and and I associate that
with anxiety and excitement I'm going to
hold that and I'm going to go for it so
it's the sort of um long-winded way of
saying pH the fair and
anyway um one question on this front um
so one thing that I struggle with in my
relationship for example is that if
um let's call her Jane if if Jane is
upset with something that I have I have
done in some kind of way yeah then I'll
feel this strong thing of like oh no I I
I need to change my behavior I need to
sort of do something differently to make
her not feel upset and whenever I have
that thought I'm always like uh I feel
feels kind of weird because it's like
yeah I can't make anyone not upset and
actually this thing that I'm I have done
is like something that I actually do
value and maybe it's just okay that
she's upset and I was talking to my
sister-in-law about this and you know in
the context of you know she was saying
when her husband leaves on a business
trip she she feels sad and I was like oh
but then like you know why is he going
on these business trips and she was like
oh well I mean I it it's it's okay that
I feel sad of course I'm going to feel
sad but like that doesn't mean he
shouldn't go and that was kind of like a
weird thing for me because in my mind
it's like managing someone else's
emotions sort of feels like my job but
when whenever I think that I'm like no
that's just not the way do you get what
I mean yeah and and that makes
relationships then
feel difficult if you have to make sure
they feel a certain way all of the time
because it's impossible to control that
right because there'll be certain
emotions that come up not because of you
but because of something else um and
then it all feels very
uncontrollable um and and and it's a
sign isn't it that if you if you feel
uncomfortable with their distress in
some ways that's a sign of how much you
care for someone so it's it's okay to
kind of hold that without acting on it
or just to communicate you know whenever
I see you upset I have that urge to try
my best to make it all go away way um
but sometimes that isn't even what's
necessary is it it's that you know
people often get that when someone's
crying so you know you get that sort of
I've got to make this go away and and
that's when people say things that
aren't necessarily helpful because um
they might say something that kind of
minimizes the distress or the problem
and um and what they're trying to do is
immediately get the person to sort crime
because their distress feels
uncomfortable to us um and actually what
they need to do is feel validated yeah
this is painful why this is okay you
know I've got your back I'm here for you
and we'll walk through this together and
then the emotion will come down
naturally anyway so when you're both
willing to contain that and sit with
that you know if you go to therapy for
example and you feel lots of raw emotion
and the tears are coming and a therapist
won't try to stop you from
crying they will sit with you through
that and help you to contain that safely
so that it takes it natural course and
and at some point um that will tail off
and and you'll feel something different
and then you on to the next experience
yeah I think whenever I see someone
crying I always feel like uh oh this is
a problem that I must solve and it's
like the natural urge to be like you do
something yeah and it's interesting
isn't it sometimes you will even cause
it because you know if someone's really
tense and anxious or if they've had a
terrible day and then you go in for a
hug and then who it all comes out and
and often that's because that person's
been holding on to lots of stuff the
whole time and the minute someone shows
compassion and care they feel safe
enough to sort of release whatever
emotion is there and so that can
sometimes come out in tears and then you
think I know I've caused it maybe I
shouldn't you know go near you or what's
going on and then you start sort of
questioning yourself about what you
should do and that's often based around
the want to control the the emotions of
the situation rather than allowing
whatever comes up to just be and then
communicating that you know what
whatever we feel we're just going to be
curious about that and we're going to
you know um that's another thing that
comes up a lot in therapy um is turning
from judgment to curiosity so rather
than thinking a certain emotion needs a
certain emotion needs to be squashed or
pushed away yeah we're just going to be
curious about all of them what's that
what's this about why is this what is
this feeling and why is it here and
what's what does that show us and then
maybe it doesn't show us anything maybe
we just let it pass like you were saying
it's it's like a piece of information
that youly to be like huh I wonder if I
should you know change something based
on this or not yeah like sometimes your
partner's upset because there's
something going on in the relationship
and sometimes they're upset because
they're having a rough time and we just
have to kind of soothe our way through
that and be there together and sometimes
that's enough too nice what are your
thoughts on the idea of U I've kind of
heard two perspectives on this that if
you're if it's night time and you're
having an argument with your partner
one's call of thought is and Ne never go
to bed angry and like hash it out and
another scho of thought is no no no
absolutely go to bed angry because
you'll you'll get over it by the morning
yes yeah I I'm to well I can see both
sides to it but um I would totally sit
on the second one really because you
sometimes when you're in a really high
emotion State you're not in a position
to resolve anything because you're both
so angry with each other or upset with
each other or and so the words coming
out your mouth aren't helpful um but
could cause more damage and so it's okay
to take time out and go and sort of calm
the system get back to somewhere close
to um a calm State um but sleep does
that for us right you know you can go to
bed feeling something really
uncomfortable or intense and then you
can wake up the next day and think I
feel fine enough yeah um and sometimes
you don't but yeah I would say if if
taking a break from each other or having
a sleep is what is necessary to help
bring that emotion down so that you can
talk to your partner with more respect
as you resolve something then do it nice
yeah a a friend of mine mentioned this
to me it was it was a couple months ago
and I was you know he's he's been
married for a few years so I kind of
asked him you know what's what's the
secret and he said oh man the one secret
is that he set a ground rule that like
after 10 p.m. you're not going to have
any
arguments cuz he was like yeah his his
wife would like they'd be in bed and the
wife would then bring something up like
a grievance or something and in the
early days of the relationship he would
like respond and they'd end up up until
like 3:00 in the morning trying to Hash
it out and not get enough sleep and then
feel a bit miserable and he was just
like you know what if there's something
to be talked about it can be done before
10: p.m. and he said that just that one
change made such an enormous difference
to their relationship yeah and and
because then also if you know start
arguing into the night and then you're
both also sleep deprived for the next
day so it's unlikely to be resolved for
a few days until you're both um kind of
in your right mind again so yeah I'd say
that's pretty good do you and your
husband have any sort of relationship
rituals like a weekly date night or like
a weekly discussion meeting yeah I I
know some people do that sort of stuff
no and and you know what we we're so
busy
um we used to kind of you know before we
had children there were lots of holidays
and going out and socializing and all
those things um but now we genuinely you
know love spending time as a family and
when we're not doing that we work
together anyway so well he he still
works um during the day at his own thing
and then we make the content together in
the evening so we spend time together
and we're being creative together
sometimes that's fun sometimes it's not
so you know sometimes it's just a work
element to it and you're grinding and
and I'm kind of you know we're trying to
film and I'm sat there kind of swearing
at myself thinking I just don't want to
be doing this right now and he's trying
to encourage me come on um all the other
way around um so no I don't do we have
any rituals I don't know um not sort of
really Salient ones that I can say that
is our ritual I'm sure we have little
things um probably something that's
really helpful that's developed over the
years of knowing each other is humor and
being able to find humor in moments that
could turn into something so I think
when you're younger and you're in the
early days of a
relationship things that um often turn
into something because maybe because
you're not so secure in yourself or
secure in the relationship that maybe
they need hashing out maybe those things
need those discussions in the early
years and then you once you've been
together a while you know where that's
going you know it's the same old thing
so you can always kind of laugh at each
other's imperfections and um or we can
anyway um but we've known each other for
a long time so um yeah sometimes we can
kind of start to moan and then we It all
becomes a bit of a joke and and we laugh
it off and then it just it helps you to
get this sort of perspective you just
sort of shift out for a minute and you
get this bird ey view of everything and
how ridiculous it is and then you carry
on the life
nice um so changing GE slightly um we we
asked our viewers and listeners of the
podcast through our telegram Community
which will be linked Down Below in the
video not video description show notes
um what they wanted to hear from you and
like loads of people were asking
questions around how to manage stress
and how to manage overthinking okay so I
wonder if we can kind of dive into those
um so one of our listeners Amar asked um
do you have any practical tools for
dealing with overthinking so I guess
like what is overthinking and like how
do we how do we manage it yeah I guess
overthink is that term isn't it that's
sort of um been used a lot online that I
probably hadn't really sort of used
clinically before that um and I think
what people are referring to is worry
right so it's that kind of I'm thinking
about things way too much I'm going
around and around in circle it's almost
like that kind of thought washing
machine isn't it where you're just
churning it over and over and and
sometimes you know if that's about the
past that would be we'd call that
rumination so you know you're just
turning over something again again and
again but in a really nonproductive way
that's not going to come to any kind of
resolution and actually rumination is a
key predictor of the sort of Maintenance
of depression or the or relapse of
depression as well so that rumination of
going over things in the past tends to
get you down um whereas worry or
overthinking about the future and that
kind of churning over often it's
catastrophizing thoughts that kind of
thing the worst case scenarios what am I
going to do if what am I going to do
when um that leads to anxiety right
because we're starting to think of um
the future not necessarily in a positive
way but in a um the worst case scenario
way and predicting I'm not going to cope
way so then you get more and more
anxious and when you're anxious then it
creates this sense of um those things
demand your attention even more so you
feel like you need to spend more time
thinking about these things because
you're convincing yourself that you're
going to come to a resolution but when
you're worrying you're not really
answering the catastrophizing questions
so the what ifs you know you kind of
repeat them in your mind what if this
happens what if that happens um and
you'll recognize that through if you're
having it as a conversation so if you're
you know with your partner for example
you're saying well we can't do that
because what if that and then they might
come up with a resol well then we'll
sort it out this way but but what if
that and what if that and and so you
realize that no matter how much the
other person tries to reassure you you
will find another catastrophizing
thought to come up with um so you know
you got those two kind of areas of I
think what people are referring to as
overthinking yeah ni different emotions
so I had I had a bit of a a moment when
he said I think I think the first thing
you said was that overthinking is
basically just worrying and I was like
oh it is yeah cuz I I guess overthinking
is a word a lot of people use but they
wouldn't necessarily use the word I'm
worried but actually I'm worried is like
you know let's call a spade a spade yeah
so so worry about the past leads to well
rumination on the path to depression
worry about the future leads to anxiety
because of the fear of bad things
happening
yeah and neither option is anything you
you really do anything about so like
it's a somewhat unproductive cycle of
thinking and and again that's where
living in a mindful way and using mind
of skills helps you to stay in the
present because uh in the very present
if all we have is right now then there's
much less to fear and feel depressed
about and in the Here and Now for for
most people so you know mindfulness is
is not about never thinking about the
because we need to right we need to live
as if we have a future um and it's not
about never thinking about the past and
finding resolution in that it's about
recognizing which thoughts arrive and
which ones are actually useful to you
which ones can lead somewhere and which
ones are just churning over and over and
causing you distress so it's about kind
of observing thoughts that arrive
noticing what emotions they bring with
them and how they make you feel and
where they tend to take you because I
think with overthinking it often tends
to be the same thing over and over again
so you know where it goes right so in
the end you you get once you've sort of
been mindful for a while you get to know
okay I know that if I go down this path
I know how I'm going to feel I know
where it's going to go and then just by
doing that you get this kind of little
window of opportunity that opens up
where you you get to choose whether you
go down that road sometimes you will
or you do something different and you
you know you turn your mind back to the
present and you almost wait for the next
thing to come um and the next experience
or you um you know mindfully participate
so you're very active mindfully so
you'll do something that uh draws your
attention to the here and now because if
the the worries I mean I did that I talk
about it in the book I think um where
when when we first learned about
mindfulness as clinical trainees and my
cohort it's kind of embarrassing really
you'd imagine that a bunch of training
psychologists would be really
open-minded and um had sort of nice
audience to teach that kind of stuff to
and I remember feeling terrible for the
the teachers at the time because it was
a room full of sort giggles and messing
around and and everyone was thinking are
we really going to teach this is this
helpful uh this feels a bit wishy-washy
and I was absolutely a cynic when I
first learned about it and it wasn't
until we got to it was exam season we
were coming up to the vior exams and I
had you know different things due in
stressful time and at the time that
that's when I used to kind of go out for
a little run in the afternoon as a way
of just getting away from the desk and
dessing and so when I I went for the um
for this run and I thought I'm just
going to try this mindfulness thing
while I'm running let's just see right
okay so and I'm I'm running through a
sort of Forest track on gravel so I just
focused on the sound of my feet on the
gravel as as my anchor to the hear and
now so that was the thing that's
happening right now is what I can hear
and what I could see around me in the
forest and stuff and thoughts of emails
deadlines career possibilities or you
know what what on Earth is going to
happen to me after I qualify those or
will I ever even qualify those kind of
things those thoughts came all the time
that you know probably thousands of
times during that run but each time I
noticed that thought or noticed that I'd
gone off with one of those thoughts I
just P myself back to the sound and I
probably brought my mind back you know a
thousand times and then as I got the end
of that run I
thought okay okay I get this it's not
it's not that you have this goal of
ultimate focus and no other thoughts
distract you and you know a kind of Monk
style kind of image you know that
stereotypical thing that people think of
it was more that I chose I constantly
made a choice about where I was going to
place my attention in those moments and
that gave me you know for this sort of
half hour jog or whatever it was it
meant that I chose chose not to worry
for that time I chose not to overthink
everything I knew I couldn't do anything
about it right I'm out in the r Forest
running um so I chose to just focus on
the hair and now for that time and you
know it it was in those sort of micro
moments a little break for my brain but
it was work in a sense that I had to
keep bringing my attention back and
that's the thing is is mindfulness isn't
um sort of an indulgent rest you know
it's not like deep relaxation it
it's almost gymm for the mind so you're
building that mental muscle to be able
to notice where your mind is notice if
it's helpful for you or not and then
bring it back to now um and sometimes
that's really difficult to do and
sometimes as soon as you bring your mind
back it's gone again and you have to do
it again and again um but yeah nice
that's the best description of
mindfulness I've ever had because i'
I've always got like obviously
mindfulness is a big buzz word yeah but
that idea that mindfulness is BAS
basically drawing your attention to the
present moment yeah on purpose on
purpose which means that the thoughts
are there and then the thoughts leave
but again you're not like attaching to
them or overidentifying with them I kind
of found myself doing this last night so
I was um sort of very jet liked because
I got back from America yesterday and I
couldn't sleep until like 5:00 a.m. and
so it's like literally hours in bed just
like lying there and you I was already
bit sleep deprived sleep on the plane
and I was in this sort of like negative
like kind of mental space where I was
then thinking about this conference I
was at last week and like a few things
that happened there and what that means
for the business what that means for my
life and what that means for my
relationship but I was it was kind of
like huh this is actually just like an
unproductive sort of thought process to
have right now because I also I also
recognized that so it was a a Tony
Robbins concert well I say concert it
was sort of a cross between a concert
and a and a seminar last week and one of
the things he often talks about is being
in the right like state to make
decisions about certain things and I was
I I was kind of thinking to myself okay
I'm overthinking all this stuff about
the business and about life but right
now it's the middle of the night it's
kind of hot like I'm sleep deprived this
is just not a good time to worry about
this stuff and so I was I was trying to
kind of draw my attention to my breath
and things like that and then I would
sort of count like okay I got I got up
to like seven and then I would just
forget because the mind would wander
again and I would bring him back to the
breath to be like nope it's all good and
after a few cycles of this I kind of
just had a moment of Serenity where I
was like that's fine everything is just
fine as it is like Life's good um and I
F I find that whenever I have these
sorts of moments I almost like love to
myself because the conclusion is always
everything is actually just fine as it
is like yeah I don't need to worry so
much about the stuff if I could do
something about it I'll do something
about it cool action point let's talk to
this person about this thing on
Wednesday when I meet them like whatever
um and yeah it's so tempting isn't it
when we start to that you know the Mind
wants to be busy and you know you kind
of it's so tempting to go down that
route and try and solve one of life's
problems while it would be most helpful
for you kind of go off to sleep isn't it
and um so I actually use mindfulness a
lot um in that same way that if if I
sort of get into bed of my mind is busy
on things um I'll just focus on like the
physical sensation of being in the bed
and the kind of you know what's the
texture of the sheets what's the
temperature of the room all that kind of
thing that just kind of brings you back
and um kind of says yeah not now worries
I'm I'm doing this and I find that
really helpful nice um one of the things
you talk about in the book is to use a
distancing language what what is what is
that H yeah so um something from
acceptance and commitment therapy so act
or ACT therapy um we talk about so
things like thought diffusion and and
getting this kind of separation from um
thoughts and emotions really so um there
are lots of different techniques you can
use but it I I use the kind of um
example of you can remember the Jim
Carrey movie The Mask you probably can't
you too young aren you but I think I saw
on one time yeah um actually I was
talking about it recently at um I think
it was a happy place festival and I I
said oh doesn't remember the video the
mask and I was like what's up
video who's this old lady talking to us
um so yeah in The Mask so uh Jim KY
finds this kind of like nothing looking
wood old wooden mask and looks like
nothing but when he puts it on and he
holds it close to his face it kind of
grasps around the back of the head and
then it controls everything he does
everything he says thinks everything um
but again if he takes it off and he just
holds it at arms length he gets to see
the mask for what it is which is just a
mask and it then has no control over how
he feels or what he does and it it's a
bit like that with thought
diffusion it's it's taking so we talked
about thoughts are not facts holding a
thought as a fact or thinking because
I've thought that it must be true is a
bit like putting it here it's your kind
of you're blinker in yourself from
seeing any other perspective yeah so all
you're doing is taking a thought from
kind of here to here and you're going
okay now I can see it for what it is
which is one possible perspective and
then you've got all this space to kind
of consider other things as well so
sometimes uh like a really simple
technique might be okay if you're um
lots of those thoughts are causing you
distress um writing them down but not
only writing them down starting that
sentence with I'm having thoughts that
or I'm noticing the thought that so
you're immediately kind of priming your
mind for this is a thought this is not
I'm not writing a fact I'm writing a
thought or a perspective or the story
I'm telling myself is or the narrative
currently is those kind of beginnings of
sentences can just help to give you that
extra arm length so that you can see
that thought for what it is and and just
something as simple as that can take
some of the power out of it U or some
people with um different anxiety
disorders like OCD will um kind of uh
give a name to a certain type of
thoughts or you know if there are lots
of anxious thoughts they might give that
person an a you know that that's that as
if there's a sort of person with having
those thoughts and you know thank you
Elgen or whatever it is for you know
thank you for bringing those thoughts
and and all you're doing when you just
give little comments like that is you're
just taking a step back from it so
you're getting a bird's eyee view on it
um so that it's not here blocking your
view of everything else nice that's so
good yeah I think that's I I guess
that's one of the benefits of journaling
that you yeah write the things down and
I often find myself saying you know like
my internal narrative is blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah yeah and then
I'll once it's down on paper or on the
iPad I'll be like okay well that's just
clearly abs because that's just not true
yeah but when it's in in the mind it's
so easy for the mind to convince itself
that that's true whereas written down on
paper it's like okay well clearly this
is just BS yeah right and and some
people will kind of have a thought and
think I just I can't even write it down
it just feels too you know it feels too
um embarrassing or you know exposing to
write it down and sometimes that's
because we're buying into it more than
we preps could or should and so yeah the
process of writing it down and the
feeling of exposure that comes with
writing it down even if no one else can
see it is you kind of always getting
honest with yourself about let's kind of
put this to the test and see if um see
if I can kind of still feel the same way
about it once I've written it down on a
piece of paper have you have you come
across the work by Byron Katy yeah yes
yeah yeah I started like that was that
was one of the books I I started reading
last night when I couldn't sleep because
at this Tony Robbins event he was kind
of talking about this method um I
thought I just find it really helpful
it's like these um these four questions
when you're having having a thought or
or some kind of limiting belief um
question number one is this
true and then just asking yourself yes
or no like you know the the body will
have a response to that yeah question
number two is this really true it's like
huh actually perhaps it's not and the
way that that that you know he was
talking about it at this this business
conference was a lot of us will um have
these limiting beliefs about what we can
or what we can't do and we'll say you
know in my case that oh you know I
shouldn't I can't grow my business
because if I do it'll mean my lifestyle
is going to is is going to become more
stressful like is that true is that
really true is like have I actually
examined all the evidence and like
landed at this conclusion that growing a
business always means that the owner
becomes more
stressed and writing it down and asking
those questions um and then you know the
next like question three would be
something like how does it make you feel
to identify with that thought and then
question four is how would it make you
feel if you just chose not to identify
with that thought yeah and then you do
like a a turnaround I think she called
call it where you sort
of write down the exact opposite of
which which in this context would be the
more the more my business grows the less
trust I'll be yeah and you find reasons
to support that and just like a very
simple stepbystep process where I was
like damn this is actually bloody
helpful yeah and and you know it's a
really it's a sort of interesting um I
say variation of it's kind of CBT in
some ways that CBT will look at okay um
thought challenging so it's you know um
and that would be one way to do a
thought challenge is just asking
yourself is it true often when we're
really stuck with a thought and it's
causing us a lot of distress it's
because we genuinely buy into it and so
you know once you get to the point of
therapy and you ask someone is that
thought true they will say yes and and
they do believe in it and that's why
they're in such pain and so sometimes
it's not enough and and that's when you
can go into the sort of um challenging
that thought so uh looking at the
evidence so is it true through okay
let's let's just play around with the
idea of taking it to court and and what
where is the evidence not only in my
opinions but what evidence would stand
up in court to say this is true and then
looking at the other side where's the
evidence that it might not be true or
might not be the best reflection of
reality right now and you can go into
doing all that kind of thought
challenging stuff looking at both sides
getting really honest with yourself
about it and you can get help with like
um from Friends and stuff to do that if
you're not in therapy um cuz sometimes
it's really difficult when you're really
stuck on something to even consider
other options and that's why you're
stuck right because it's not easy um but
for some people that's not the best way
because it can set up an argument in
your mind and then you're just
ruminating on you know so you can kind
of try and go down for the you the all
the evidence that this thought isn't
true and then your mind just keeps
coming back with yeah but yeah but this
is the reason it's true this is the
reason it's true and you end up almost
in more distress because you're just
going back and forth with this sort of
internal argument um and that's when the
ACT stuff is super helpful so the
diffusion stuff so it's like actually do
you know what true or not I'm just going
to push this sort to there Y and I'm
just going to see it for what it is for
a minute and I'm going to try and hold
it lightly and I know that that's one
option I can go down that and I can I
can go down that route and I can kind of
fuse with that thought and I can spend
time with it where is that going to take
me and what are my other options and and
sort of holding those options
lightly um which is in some ways a bit
more mindful so rather than getting into
the nitty-gritty and and trying to find
the truth it's acknowledging that often
a truth is a mixture of different
opinions and not one and you're you know
sometimes you're never going to find the
truth um and being okay with that kind
of holding that lightly and moving on to
the next
experience yeah one of the things I find
helpful is that
um almost almost that there is no truth
it's just you know generally if I think
of
the the disempowering thoughts that I
have they're not things that are like
objectively true or not it's not like
I'm I'm not going to be ruminating by
the fact that I cannot physically bench
200 kg but I might be thinking oh my
content is not Val able people don't
like me um I'm going to become
irrelevant like oh I'm I'm a bad public
speaker whatever what whatever the thing
might be but these things like you know
I was I was speaking to my cousin the
other day in the car and she just
casually threw out the phrase oh I'm
just really lazy and I was like are you
is that you know is that true and she
never really questioned that belief
because I guess a belief is just a
thought that we I that that we hold with
some level of certainty and we sort of
went went over the evidence a bit I was
like I don't know I mean to me it
doesn't look like you're lazy cuz you're
doing this this this and this like how
how do you feel about that she was like
oh yeah I mean I guess when you put it
that way you know perhaps I'm not lazy
and it was it was such it was almost a
revelation for her to be like Oh I'm not
actually lazy oh like I've been
telling myself the story for such a long
time but I find it helpful to imagine
the idea that there there is no truth
it's just a matter of a thought that we
believe because we have certainty with
it yeah and actually there are way way
more options out there than believing
that one specific thought that I lazy or
I'm a bad public speaker or whatever the
thing might be and that's where labeling
thoughts can be really helpful too so
you know noticing a thought for what it
is is often you know with that situation
it's as you have the thought
recognizing that's a judgment or that's
a self-criticism or that's an opinion or
that's a memory or that's a story I tell
myself or that's a prediction about the
future or there's a catastrophizing
thought so you know there are lots of
different types of thoughts none of
which would qualify for giving fact as
it is so as soon as you can kind of
notice the you know be mindful of a
thought notice it and then label it as
oh yeah that's a you know self-critical
Judgment of mine then then you're in a
better position to be able to um take it
for what it is and and not buy into it
you still might hold it there and you
still might feel like you're lazy but
noticing that it's anind way of speaking
to yourself and an unhelpful kind of
thought pattern or an opinion
um helps you to kind of helps it to
carry less weight yeah and have less
effect on how you feel yeah like you're
holding it at arms length again yeah so
it's it's almost like this idea like
thought like labeling labeling this as a
narrative or as a story or as a memory
or as a
self-criticism helps helps it sort of be
like oh actually it's just that wooden
mask yeah that I can hold a little bit
away from well that sounds like you did
a really great sort of thought
challenging exercise with her so I'm
done thank you by the way in case you
haven't heard the book that I've been
working on for the last 3 years is now
available for order it is called
Feelgood productivity and it's available
on Amazon and all other major retailers
and you can check out the website
Feelgood productivity.com for more
information and links to where you can
get yourself a copy I really like the
thing about like with the stup in court
again I've been blessed not to really
suffer with any mental health problems
but for for example if someone is highly
anxious or highly depressed and
a depressed person might might think
life will never be good again and
obviously that one stood up in court and
I like the I've got a few friends who
have experienced that and I kind of ask
them about this that like in in that
moment like you obviously know it's not
true um that like life will be better
and they were like yeah you kind of know
intellectually that it's not true but
like you feel emotionally and in your
soul that like of course it's true um so
I guess to what extent does challenging
thoughts in Court help with the more
extreme forms ofal health problem and
that's where it takes um more time and
effort like you were saying about the
the um the sort of questions from the
book that you've read and um those can
be really really helpful with in sort of
in a a light way but when someone is
really depressed um you often spend you
can spend a lot of time on something
like thought challenging or and and and
working out whether that's helpful or
whether move to something like diffusion
and kind of just separating from it and
allowing it to be there because you know
that's the that's the bind in depression
is that it's not that this thought
appeared out of nowhere and then made
you feel depressed the two are occurring
at the same time so when you're when
you're depressed you're more likely to
have those thoughts yeah and you're more
likely to believe in them and and and
when you're having those thoughts you're
then more likely to feel more depressed
and so it's this kind of cycle this
downward spiral that you're kind of
stuck in um and so you know therapy is
often a a process of chipping away
chipping away chipping away there isn't
this sort of one turning point where you
go oh okay yeah the future could be fine
and and then everything's okay it's a
sort of well you know often we'll do um
a thought challenging task and you'll
rate at the beginning so you'll get your
thought that's causing distress and
you'll rate maybe give it a percentage
on how much you really believe that
thought to be true and how much you buy
it and it might be 100% It's Not Unusual
for it to be 100% um and then you'll do
all your different exercises kind of
trying to challenge it and you're not
trying to turn it on its head as much as
loosen it off you know just holding it
lightly so um you might then after
you've done some of those thought
challenging exercises rate it again for
how much you believe in it and that
might go from 1% to 60 or 70% and that's
success right so that's just slightly
loosening so you're allowing yourself to
consider that there could be other ways
of looking at this and that would be
okay movement progress and then you know
move on to the next thing and and that's
why these things take time right that's
why no one can rush in and convince
someone not to be depressed because
there's lots of different layers and
everything's binding it together um from
different Avenues and different kind of
angles um so you have to kind of pick it
apart like those weaves in the basket
nice I guess one one of the things that
came up when we were doing um you know
asking the audience as well about about
the podcast is this the idea of positive
thinking where like posit like it's it
sounds like some of the stuff you know
we were talking about reframing earlier
yeah that sounds like it could be quote
positive like what is positive thinking
because if that that also feels like one
of these buzzwordy thingies that Al
feels to be missing some kind of me and
that's where I kind of
um uh I I asked about it a lot because I
I put it in the book about the sort of
uh Positive Vibes only Trend online and
the kind of you know um don't allow
yourself to think any negative thoughts
and that kind of thing and um I don't
really buy into that side of things
because in order to do that successfully
you have to really deny your own human
brain and you know because if we think
of it as as in your brain is set up to
kind of you know help you survive but
also to help you generate meaning and
understand your environment and what's
around you yeah and what demands are
placed on you and if your brain is doing
that well then a fair degree of the time
it's going to come up with some sort of
negative ideas about what's going on
right because the world isn't you know
Barbie land or whatever um and
so if you then if if you set yourself up
with this idea of I'm not going to have
any negative thoughts I'm going to be so
positive and then you inevitably have a
a negative evaluation of something you
then criticize yourself for being so
negative and I'm such a Negative person
and I'm this and that and then you go
down and down and down and down right
because I had a negative thought maybe
that thing was negative maybe it was an
accurate reflection of your reality um
but you then instead of using that
information you get into this spiral of
criticizing yourself for having been
negative um so again I think don't give
yourself the expectation that that you
are going to be 100% positive all of the
time just accept that you are human and
when you have a negative
thought some of those will be helpful to
you actually and some of those won't and
I think in some ways that kind of wisdom
is is being able to hold as go back to
the hold the more lightly thing and then
ask yourself which ones do I want to
spend time with is it going to be
helpful for me to spend time with this
and go deeper with it and connect with
it or is it something I can then um let
go of and move on from um we we've
talked about um you know if we move on
to if if we talk about like anxious
thought patterns um we've we've kind of
alluded to the idea of
catastrophizing um there's a few other
things that um I think talk about in the
book around you know personalizing
overgeneralizing labeling I wonder if we
can just go through some of these and
you know for people who might not be be
familiar with them so what what is
personalizing so personalizing is that
thing that we all do I mean all of these
biases are human and normal right so
they're not um pathological they are
your brain taking a quick shortcut to
help you come up with with um an
explanation for what's going on um and
possibly help your survival um but do
that really really quickly so you know
the idea that your brain only has
certain information to go on so let's
say you're um you're walking down the
street and you see someone you know on
the other side of the street so you wave
and you say hi and they don't you you
feel like they've seen you but they
don't wave back and then your brain goes
straight
to that thing I said the other day it
must have offended her she must hate me
everyone must be talking about me I'm so
awful what was I thinking how could I
say something like that and and you go
down this kind of spiral yeah and and if
you kind of get the bird's eye view from
that scenario there we could sit down
here and scribble out 10,000 Reasons Why
that person might not have smiled um but
you go down this hole of kind of
self-loathing and so you're you're
taking an event that could have lots of
explanations or could be fairly neutral
and you're making it about you and often
in a negative way that is kind of
painful or hurtful to you so you kind of
personalize stuff nice um and I guess
kind of understanding these is like if
you understand oh I'm I'm personalizing
there or I'm catastrophizing it's it's
again helpful to hold the thought at
arms length yeah and and I'm just be
able to kind of even label a thought as
personalizing it's still one possible
version of that reality right she might
hate you but also uh she might not have
put a contact lenses in yeah you know it
it happens and so um is acknowledging
that when you've
personalized you can just be free to
consider something else and or what
you're going to do about it next and or
acknowledge that you tend to um go down
that anxious route of thinking that the
worst is happening and it's down to you
and and that is your brain doing a good
job again it's not like a fault in the
system because um that is quite a big
psychological threat if you feel like
your friendship group or your imunity is
not safe or accepting of you then
historically that is a risk to your
survival you know we live in groups we
live in communities so you know back in
the day if you were rejected by that
Community your chances of survival were
pretty drastically reduced and um and
probably still today you know that the
effects of loneliness are not to be
stuffed at so um it's your brain trying
to keep you safe but it's not always the
best reflection of reality it's just the
quickest um response from your brain
that goes to the thing that's probably
going to help you to survive the most
nice what if a mental filter so mental I
did a video on this actually where I use
like a big tray um like a big cender
type thing um and I put kind of
different sized beans in to show kind of
different types of thoughts and mental
filter is often um you get this a lot
with um depression actually where the
good things that happen for example or
thoughts about things that could
actually make you feel a bit better tend
to get filtered out and kind of
disregarded and left and then what
you're left with to focus on is all the
stuff that makes you feel worse and the
negative stuff so I think in the old
it's an old video now but um I think in
the video I used the example of um let's
say you make a video and you're scanning
through the comments and you're going
past hundreds of really positive
comments and you're looking for that one
person that doesn't like you and and so
you're filtering out you know on the
screen you're filtering out all the
positive thoughts that could help you to
feel good about your content and then
you zoom in on that one thing that that
makes you feel worse and um and I did
that myself I noticed in the early days
where I was kind of looking through
comments and I was kind of scanning
quickly through these really nice
comments looking for anyone who you know
didn't like it um noticing that was the
mental filter in the moment just allowed
me to go no we're not doing this okay
put the phone away and so it's actually
more you know labeling it and noticing
what bias it is is actually more
powerful than you think because it just
allows you to kind of trip out of the um
down spiral I was uh I was interviewed
on a on a big podcast recently and the
interview interview came out about a
week ago and I find myself going back to
that YouTube video and looking at the
comments and sorting my newest cuz cuz
I've read all the comments on that video
and I'm like you know I'm so curious and
I find myself doing this as well I'm
like yeah nice comment nice comment like
oh that that's the one and I saw one
last night where it said something like
oh you know Ali ABD is just a scammer or
something like that and I was like
that's the one and then I realized wait
a minute like just skipped past like 18
oh my God this interview was incredible
Ali's so articulate he's such a humble
guy what a nice guy oh my God so helpful
best interview ever and I just fux
fixated on the one that was like I that
was a scammer this is what I'm going to
think about for the next 48 hours y your
your mental filter yeah um again just I
guess having that terminology to be like
and the visual of just okay yeah yeah
fair enough yeah this is a game that
we're not going to play so thank you
very much yeah it just enables you to
see through it and to see where it's
going to take you and then to make the
choice about whether you go with that or
whether you don't and sometimes you will
um and sometimes you'll kind of do
something different what's the
difference between Stress and
Anxiety so um I talked about this in in
the book actually I think there are
terms that again online get used sort of
interchangeably probably to mean similar
or the same things and we do have that
one stress response right so we have
that kind of threat system in our
body um and we only have the one kind of
survival response that sort of you know
fight or flight mode and stuff that
people talk about but the way that we
exper whether we conceptualize that
experience I think depends on the words
we use for it so I don't know if I was
going
to give an example let's say um let's
say you you you've got a busy day at
work but you need to post I know your
passport off or something and it's got
to be done today and you've got a gap in
your meetings or half an hour and you
know you can get to the post office
quickly post it and get
back and then you get to the post office
and there's this huge
queue and you're stood in the queue and
you suddenly start to kind of feel that
heart pounding or bit sweating and what
feels like stress and that's your body
kind of creating this increased sense of
sort of alertness to say do you know
what we might need to reprioritize here
because we might not be able to meet all
the demands placed on us we might not
get back for that meeting and then
you're trying to work work out what's
most important here is it posting this
or getting to that meeting and you might
call that stress if that was it if it
was sort of you know what demands can I
meet you might call it anxiety if you
know that you're now not going to get
back for that meeting but your boss
tends to humiliate people that turn up
late and so you're now anxious about
public
humiliation um which is more anxiety
than stress so it's really about kind of
the way we conceptualize it I think and
and often we turn things anxiety when
it's sort of more threat based or that
that kind of feeling but but people use
those terms really interchangeably these
days I think yeah as you were describing
that I there was I think it happened was
it last week or the week before where
we're often if if my girlfriend and I
are going out to dinner and we're
meeting someone there or we have like a
reservation at a restaurant for a
certain time she'll take ages to get
ready and I will find myself being like
sort of feeling the stress response to
be like come on like it's not that hard
like
you look great already like why does it
take like what the what what even is
that stuff you're putting on you're like
come on and I I often noticed that like
oh I'm feel I'm feeling stressed right
now that's fine yeah like I can just I
can just let it go and I I'll think
what's the worst that's going to happen
we're going to be late for the
restaurant that's fine yeah what if they
cancel our table great we'll just go
somewhere else and then I'll be like you
know what it's fine I'll just read a
book while to taking AG to get ready and
fig and figuring out what shoes go with
this thing or whatever the situation
might be but I find myself kind of
noticing that like oh I'm feeling
expressed right now and I you know
there's no reason to be because actually
you know the worst case scenario is
actually pretty is actually pretty
reasonable yeah yeah and the lateness is
a big one isn't it for a lot of people
because um it triggers you know for
example if someone else is making you
late but you really value being on time
maybe because you associate that with um
I don't know if you you grew up in a
family where anyone who was late was
humiliated or was put down for being I
don't know selfish or you know given
those sorts of terms then it might bring
in bring in that sort of fear of um
judgment social judgment or social
rejection and those kind of things and
yeah um and that's where sort of turning
towards any feeling with curiosity as
opposed to judgment so like I'm stressed
I'm going to try not to be about this or
um actually I'm stressed why am I
stressed about being late what what's
the worst thing about being late today
what is it I'm really scared about about
being late um is it because I know that
person that's going to be at the table
always hates it when people are um late
and I know they're going to kind of bit
about us later on or you know that kind
of thing um and once you start to
unravel it you then understand where
it's come from and it's much easier then
to to do something with it or to feel
something different about it because you
well do I really value that person's
opinion is that person really important
to me maybe the answer is yes maybe it's
no and but then you've got a sort of
chance to do something with it as
opposed to just sort of trying to make
it go away yeah yeah um you also say
that we have a LoveHate relationship
with stress uh what do you what do you
mean by LoveHate relationship uh yeah I
don't know I don't remember saying that
did I write it in the book um yeah you
wrote we humans have a LoveHate
relationship with stress we love the
thrill of a horror movie or the speed of
the roller coaster we actively choose
these spikes in our stress response and
we anticipate them um yeah I mean cuz
and and that's the thing about anxiety
as well isn't it that it's often talked
about something really negative that's
pathological about us and we need to
make it go away and that if you ever
feel anxiety it's probably because it's
something wrong with you and it's just
not true is it and and you know I love
the kind of example of the you know the
roller coasters or the horror movies
because that's an example of when we are
more accepting of those emotions so much
so that we we add them into an an
experience you you have to watch a
horror movie you could watch something
else but you choose that because the
real of that those Sensations that come
with it in what we know to be a safe
environment really um is in some way
enjoyable and it's it feels like living
it's an experience and um but then
anxiety in other situations we
conceptualize it slightly differently
that makes us just want to absolutely
eradicate it and make it go away um and
that's where I think you know shifting
your relationship with emotion generally
is just so powerful it gives you so much
Freedom if you're willing to carry the
discomfort that comes with whatever
experience it is it means that anything
that means something to you is not
necessarily out of your reach if you're
willing to feel the discomfort of
getting there um but if you're not then
a lot of the world is closed off to you
because most things that are meaningful
and um uh what's the word most things
that are sort of meaningful or feel like
achievements involve discomfort on the
way way so if you're not willing to make
yourself feel vulnerable and
uncomfortable you kind of close a lot of
doors to yourself I think nice let's
talk about burnout um but we were just
talking before we resumed while we were
grabbing coffee um this idea that you
know both of us have as content creators
I guess where there's this sort of
almost feels like a hamster wheel
sometimes of like more content is always
better because like the thing is growing
and you don't want to things up
because the thing is growing and it's
like okay well let's just triple our
output cuz we might as well and like the
thing is growing and yeah all of this
sort of the desire for more and more and
more which then gets us too sort of in
the direction of of burnout but I wonder
what's what's been your experience of
balancing more with like taking care of
yourself and having decent work life
balance oh that's been a massive
learning curve for me and it's something
I've just had to learn from experience
and I think most people do don't they
because you know we all preach it and
but then we all end up going through it
anyway and um I never imagine I don't
think anyone imagines that being a
content creator um is difficult until
you try to do it and there's something
about it is a bottomless pait that will
take from you as much as you're willing
to give and and sometimes even when
things are going well that the demand
increases right so you kind of you it's
great that it's going well but also then
uh when we first started for
example you know each video we put on
seemed to be doing better than the last
and it was all good but we felt like
okay well this will switch off at some
point it might last a week it might last
a month and then and then it'll be that
thing we did once so while it's hot
let's just go for it and and so we kind
of sort of worked in a totally
unsustainable way because we thought it
was going to all switch off at some
point and it didn't and um so the idea
of doing this for a month was okay let's
just get through this month and then
it's two and then it's six and then it's
couple of years and um and that's tough
that that's you know um
at some point you have to kind of step
back and go this isn't sustainable so
what can be sustainable but the process
of working in a way that's
unsustainable it's then really difficult
to step back and and take something away
or do less for the sake of a healthier
life yeah um I think psychologically
it's really difficult to do isn't it to
say I'm not going to make a video every
day I'm going to make three videos a
week and enjoy the rest of my life or
you know um and I guess you could apply
that to other you know lots of other
jobs or working for yourself that kind
of thing um I think psychologically is
quite difficult to do um it's almost a
sense that like oh I'm I could film a
video a day but the fact that I'm
choosing not to means that I am lazy and
that I am just not a hard worker and
like what's wrong with me and like am I
just a softy or am I not disciplined
enough or like all of this stuff and the
fact that you know all these platforms
are are made to be just as addictive to
the Creator as they are to the consumer
right so you know it's that possibility
isn't it like what if you made a video
and what if it did really well and you
know what if it led to something or
whatever that you know all those kind of
Senses of possibilities in your mind
that um that draw you into doing more
and more and more um often to the
detriment of you know some other thing
that you love doing in your life or
that's important to you I'm I'm curious
what this experience is like for you cuz
from where I'm sitting you seem to have
won the game because the book is great
like it's selling super well it seems to
be selling week on week which means that
it's not just your promotion that's
actually selling the book it's the fact
that it's good and people are
recommending it to each other so now
you're you've like won the game and so
like do you do you still feel that like
sense of like ah I want this next video
to go viral shouldn't be putting out
more content no I'm just kind of sitting
here trying to work out how Ali abdol is
saying to me I've won the game because
it's isn't that strange how you know we
both sat here um you know I did your
YouTube course and I've learned a lot
from you and you were always when we
first started on YouTube so we looked up
to yeah that's the kind of content I
want to produce it's brilliant love it
he's won the game um and you never feel
like you arrive you never feel like
you've won the game you just constantly
feel like you're playing the game yeah
right and um and still I do right
because I haven't finished I am still
going and I still got more challenges
and things ahead that we're sort of
planning on and working on and
um yeah I think the idea of it's a bit
like when we talked about the the Sunday
Times thing and and you go oh yeah good
and then the next moment comes and and
it's not as exciting or you know um or
then people go what's next and what are
you going to do now and how are you
going to do better and so you never
really win the game I think the winning
is in playing right the winning is in um
sounded really cheesy the winner is in
play no it's I'm just like yeah yeah
maybe maybe it is the winning is in is
in choosing to cuz I mean in some
ways it doesn't get any luckier than
finding yourself in a position where you
can uh do what you would do whether not
anyone's paying you or not and make it
into a living so you know my kind of my
pasttime forever has been to read you
know books about psychology and and
often popular psychology and people who
were communicating it in such a an
engaging way and and that was what I
generally did with my spare time so the
fact that I can now um say right I've
got a writing task I'm going to see what
you know what research is out there or
what great books are out there and um
and I get to call that work that's
that's probably winning the game yeah
whatever views we get and I'm genuinely
don't really um this is probably really
bad and I but I um I don't really sort
of look twice at kind of numbers or
Analytics and stuff like that and my
husband's really into it and he'll kind
of say oh that that video is doing well
and I've forgotten to even look and and
see you know what it's done or um and I
think that helps a lot that I don't base
any of my idea of success on on that
stuff um how do you how do you not
because like that's a hard place you
know I've spoken to a lot of book
authors who you know a lot of content
creators will Peg their self worth to
their subscribe account their follow
account and their l 10 view average or
something all of authors will Peg the
self worth to how many copies they've
sold and yeah whether they had the best
out the list or not like do you know I I
seriously think having children has
helped hugely with that because when I
think of my daughter said to me once she
said how does it feel to have this
million you know this many million
followers and um and I kind of looked at
her and I thought I I for a moment she
was probably kind of looking at that in
a way that I didn't want her to look at
it and
and I didn't want her to feel any less
for not having that and and so I was
very clear that it means absolutely
nothing it really doesn't and um while
it's been fun at times um if if I
accidentally delete the account I'm
still me nothing's really different and
um my day-to-day life would be different
right i' have more free time but um uh
but yeah I'm I'm still I'm know more or
less of me having that or not having
that and and it could all switch off
tomorrow right I could say something
online that made everybody hate me and
and it would all be
over um but I'm lucky enough that I
think it started late enough in life
that I know what's most important to me
and I know it's all kind of a bit silly
and um that you know people unfollow me
every day and that's okay I'm okay with
that but maybe that's also a position of
privilege that because my husband kind
of looks at that stuff and and the
analytics that I don't have to that as a
business obviously you know people need
to do that and then I think once you're
in it it's almost really difficult to
not become attached to those numbers so
yeah it's probably sort
of privileged ignorance
maybe floating along nicely making a few
random videos I don't I don't look at
YouTube analytics anymore either I just
sort of I like you know ttin know
YouTube producer is amazing and our
editing team is amazing yeah I don't
even review videos before they come out
now a video will just come out and I'll
notice oh got some got some YouTube
notifications I'll be on the toilet be
oh video came out I'll watch it I'll be
like sick editing actually worked really
well and it's like comes as a surprise
to me when a videoos come because I'm
like oh nice this the things things are
being done um but this is to quote this
business conference I was at last week
their whole vibe was that if you are a
business operator then growth is
stressful yeah and if you're a business
owner and you have an operator who's
like dealing with the day-to-day and you
can be the owner doing the stuff that
you really want to do then grow is not
stressful at all both is actually really
fun yeah yeah and so it sounds like you
and I are both sort of in that position
where we're the sort of the talent as it
were and you've got Matt and I've got my
guys doing the stuff yeah uh which means
that we have the privilege of focusing
on the content and putting a message out
there without having to worry too much
about the analytics just Swan along
doing the creative stuff exactly I just
rock up and then Amber andard are the
ones doing the research for the episode
looking at the analytics and analyzing
all of our stuff to be like okay yeah um
and I'm just like cool I just rock up
and have a chat like life is good I
think quite early on I real realized
that if um if I started to even by into
the positive stuff like yeah that video
went so viral and so awesome and then
the next one flopped um you know if you
if you I don't know if if you um attach
or associate your selfworth to the
positive you're also going to lose out
massively when the negative happens
which it does right and um and so I try
not to attach s Worth to the good or the
bad too much and just go with the kind
of this is a fun experience and while
it's all good and we appear to be being
useful to people then that's great um
but also you know the day it all stops
it'll be like that was a cool ride that
was fun that's a very healthy way of
looking at it as as you would like when
you said that thing about oh you know
someone deleted my thing I had like I
was like oh if someone deleted my
YouTube channel I would lose like the
single biggest source of meaning in my
life whereas you've got the family and
so I imagine that takes a lot of the
boxes of for like connection and
meaningful contribution and service and
all this kind of stuff yeah and in some
ways you know um the the accounts and
stuff it pulls me away from them so in
some ways it's a sort of it would be a
relief I don't mean that it wouldn't be
but it's um yeah I think I think having
already got to a point in my life where
I had a profession that I know I can
always go back to right I I know I can
always go back to you know bums on seats
and seeing people in the room which I I
loved that part of the job and it was I
just found it such a privilege so I know
that the bits of that that I miss I
could I could go back to and enjoy and
um so it's not you know it's probably
more privileged position than a lot of
people if um they've you know remortgage
the house and put lots of stuff into
this thing and then they're trying to
you know keep a roof over their heads by
making something work um whereas I know
I've got other things I can do if if it
doesn't work out yeah I think once
you're out of survival mode then a lot
of it then becomes like I mean I mean
I'm definitely out of survival mode but
I still Peg an unhealthy amount of
myself s worth on like the fact that
like the identity of of being a big
YouTuber and it's like that feels good
and it's like I feel like doing
something useful and all this so if
the channel disappeared
overnight well it's I mean honestly if
the channel be overnight i' be like
great let's do something else let's
start build that app that I've been
wanting to do for a while and just
haven't had the chance to do because of
content and stuff yeah that's a good
place to be yeah to to know that um you
would continue and still be you and and
the fact that you built something means
you could probably build something else
and that you've you've used and
developed so many skills through the
experience whether that's developing a
YouTube channel or something else that
you know if it stops at any point then
you use everything you've learned along
the way to try something new and go for
it yeah I was speaking to a friend
yesterday who recently got fired from
his job um sort of big Finance bro who's
been like succeeding in all fronts and
it's like and this is the first time
he's had like a setback and he was
saying that like it was actually a great
experience because he's realized oh
being fired is not that big a deal he
had al already had like loads of
freelance gigs coming through linked and
he's like ohuh you know this thing of
like working a few hours a day is
actually quite nice and before he'd been
like oh my God being fir would be the
worst thing ever because my whole
identity is tied up in the fact that I'm
a finance bro but now he's like I can
chill yeah life is good yeah and so I
guess maybe that's I I I noticed this
with students a lot um I I I I
definitely had periods of this when I
was a student as well where it's like an
unhealthy amount of selfworth would be
pegged to the result of the exam and
then the exam comes and goes and whether
you pass whether you fail whatever this
the thing is you realize
H it's not such a big idea it's it's
it's not such a big deal life goes on
and actually there are sources of
meaning in life ideally other than exam
grades yeah I mean I I struggle to it's
weird isn't it you get to a point in
your life where you struggle to remember
what the results
were
um but what you I think what you take
away from the process of of doing things
like exams or going to UNI is you learn
how hard you're willing to work to get
to where you want to go so I remember
getting to
UNI um I went to EXA for my undergrad
and um and we went in with a tutor and
and he said
um uh you know this you know few people
or whatever get first and everyone's
kind of slammed in the chairs and he
said well but you know anyone can do it
but it's you know the fact that you're
all here means it's
possible but it's about how hard you're
willing to work to get there and how
many hours you're willing to put in and
that was when my sort of ears picked up
and I thought okay came on let's I I
could do hard work let's let's go for it
and that was you know just seeing it as
um uh you know good things are available
to you um with hard work yeah kind of in
empowered me to feel that I would give
it a shot whereas if you know if if it
was just sort of like results based only
that this few number of people get a
first for example then I would probably
have thought that would never be me I'm
just a normal person I'm just average
you know average Jew um so you know know
seeing something I think the thing that
you learn along all of those things is
um you you get the evidence you get to
witness yourself grinding and working
hard towards something and enduring
setbacks and all that stuff and then
you've got that in the bank that you
know the next time something difficult
comes up I can get through this that's
fine a challenge is not the end of
everything a challenge is is a sign that
I need to get into gear and face this so
I I think then you just use that again
again and again regardless of ABC or D
or one to n whatever it is now yeah
that's like there it's it's quite an
empowering thought or belief that hey
whatever happens I'll rise to I'll rise
to the challenge and I'm sure I can
figure it out based on past experiences
yeah and and I think um I don't know
maybe I'm making that sound sort of
oversimplified because I know there are
lots of problems in life um where it's
just huge and you don't know if you're
coming or going and you know big awful
things are
happening um
and and that's when you can feel
overwhelmed and you're less likely to
think oh this is a challenge and lot of
threat and um but then there are also
skills to to deal with you know those
really really difficult moments that
probably slightly different and it's
probably about kind of soothing your way
through stuff but um yeah what do you
mean soothing your way through
stuff so in uh dialectical behavior
therapy so DBT which is um a year-long
therapy um they teach emotion coping
skills and one of those emotion coping
so emotion coping skills is split up
into sort of different segments
depending on what they're needed for So
within sort of um uh emotion regulation
skills you would also have distress
tolerance skills so you have emotion
regulation skills or the skills that you
use to keep your emotions fairly
balanced but then what if something
happens and your emotion are kind of out
of whack or they're really intense then
you need distress tolerance skills so
how do you get through highly
distressing disturbing periods of your
life safely um and you that's the
moments when it it's all hit the fan you
know you are overwhelmed you don't know
what to do and you've just got to get
through um so self soothing is one of
those skills so um that's when you're
teaching people not to try to squash the
feeling or do the the the thing that's
going to make it disappear right now but
you're going to regret
later um but to look after yourself
through the discomfort so um I think I
did a video on this a long time ago
about doing um like self soothing boxes
so we'll often do that in DBT will'll
get people to just get a shoe box or
something and they'll they'll put in
there lots of things that help them to
soothe their way through the most
painful moments of their lives safely so
it's the idea that it's kind of mindful
to say you use all of your your senses
to um to help create that feeling of
safety and that's really what you want
to do is bring a sense of safeness to
the moment so um it might be um a piece
of music that that you know kind of
generates certain feelings for you or it
might be a perfume that you associate
with uh love and safety like um your
mom's perfume or um lavender or
something like that or um it might be
something that you can taste that you
enjoy that kind of brings you to the
present or lots of different things so
you can use all different senses so you
put different things in a box to kind of
sooe you through difficult
moments that's
nice um so we were talking about burnout
I was I want to talk about burnout um
one of the so the final three chapters
of my book feel feel good productivity
Link Link down below um I need to get
more comfortable doing the plug I'll do
it um final final three chapters we talk
about burnout and the way that I've sort
of looked looking at the research and
stuff framed things is that there are
kind of three types of of burnout that
we have different strategies for dealing
with there is um see if I can run this
there's uh overexertion burnout where
you're just working too hard and not
taking a break and on on the road to
burnout there there is depletion burnout
um which is where we're not kind of
resting enough and we sort of our energy
depleted and then there's misalignment
burnout where we're like doing the thing
but like it's not quite aligned to
whoops it's not quite aligned to where
like our values where we actually want
to go and so we end up in this phase
where like life should be good but
actually you feel the sense of burnout
because you're doing something that it
that that doesn't feel like it is
fulfilling you or something to what
extent does that Vibe with your
experience of burnner oh hugely um the
the misalignment is um a big one in that
um one of the the skills in the book
that I do on a fairly regular basis
probably every few months is the the
values check-ins because I find a lot of
people who um come along to therapy and
don't can't can't articulate really what
the problem is the kind of say I don't
really know what's going on it just
feels yeah nothing feels sort of um
meaningful or um I don't yeah I don't
feel satisfied with my
life often those
situations become really um clear once
you do a values check-in so it's often
when people have been pulled away from
the things that me matter to them and
mean a lot to them by other things in
life so and it's a really simple task
you'll often get you can do it in
different ways but you can just get a
pen and paper and you you write out the
different areas of your life so you
might have like family um Intimate
Relationships parenting friendships
health career lifelong learning
creativity whatever put them all on the
page and you kind of um ask yourself
what are the things that matter to me
most in this area of my life so not what
you want to happen to you but how you
want to show up in the area of your life
good or bad times so what you want to
bring what you want to contribute the
attitude you want to have that kind of
thing you might have a few words or
sentences bullet points and then you can
kind of rate okay out of 10 how
important are these values to me in this
area of my
life and then rate it again on how much
you feel you're living in line with that
at the moment so in the last couple of
weeks and and then you get these two
scores and you get to kind of look
across the page all the different areas
of your life and it's a really good
indication of where to kind of direct
your focus next because if you've rated
something as really highly important to
you but then you're rating for how much
you're living in line with that is like
two out of 10 there's a disparity there
that needs your attention and it might
you know it's not um it's not a path for
like self-loathing it's just because
often it's because something else has
pulled you away from it you know you
might be doing really well with another
area of your life and and it's not that
you can do them all perfectly all of the
time it's that you probably have to you
you know spin from one to another at
each point you know you can't um you
know uh I guess the work parenting thing
is a really obvious one that it's really
difficult to kind of be the parent that
you want to be all of the time and have
the career that you want to have all of
the time and so there's a a sort of um
ping ponging between the two but just
doing one of those exercises if you're
not feeling um sort of satisfied or if
you're feeling burnt out it's often an
indication that you've just sort of been
shifted away from something and you're
not okay with that so it's a sign to
shift back nice so like so you've got
the different areas of life and so in
that like for example in the family
parenting category are you asking
yourself like what are the values that
are most important to me like being
there for my kids and like picking them
from school and stuff yeah and then you
rate how important those things are to
you and then how much you're actually
living yeah that that was a that was a
big thing for me um as everything got
busier and busier with all this stuff
stuff um that I could feel myself just
feeling a bit overwhelmed and and sort
of had a look at it on the page and yeah
being present as a parent was really
important to me but I'd obviously spent
a long time locked in the office writing
the book and and doing all these
podcasts and stuff and and and I
recognized that I I needed to shift back
to being present more of the time to to
be okay with that balance and um but I
think I've talked about this before that
I think often people have this
misconception that balance is like
finding the perfect sweet spot where
you've just like you know won the game
or whatever and you you know you've got
it all right and everything's good in
your life and I just don't think it ever
happens like that I think you know if
you're sort of on a balancing beam uh
the process of balancing is a constant
shifting from like one side to another
and as you notice you're tilting too
much one way you kind of shift to tilt
the other way and counterbalance and and
and I just think life is a bit like that
and um so there's you know um like I'm
I'm here today and I'm not with my my
kids today but we're going off um as a
family at the end of the week so I know
that I can you know it's a little bit of
a shift one way or the other and and um
I think that's okay I think um because
you had tend to I think other parents
were probably Rel just that you just
feel guilty whatever you do but once you
recognize balance to be that constant
shifting and
rebalancing um it becomes slightly
easier I
think nice yeah I guess the way I I I
see the is
like ideally I would so in in my mind I
I sort of have an idea of like what does
my ideal day look like but I'm not
massively attached to that because the
day you know stuff happens and I also
have in my mind like what does what does
the ideal week look like like and an
ideal week I'd like to do I don't know
one or two date nights or like one
dinner with friends on average or like
see my mom and grandma once a week and
like go to the gym three times a week
yeah and by mapping that out on like a
Google Calendar that I call my ideal we
calendar I can just see okay cool like
this is this is my ideal kind of life
and obviously I end up like never
actually living my ideal week but just
knowing what it is and like helps me be
like okay you know for the last two
weeks I've been to the gym like once a
week let's just do a little rebalancing
there because actually I do know that
this is important to me and it's the
thing that I want to do therefore let's
do the thing so I really like the idea
of sort of like balancing this beam and
constantly shifting and adjusting I've
always liked your idea of the kind of
the ideal week and the ideal day and
that kind of thing and cuz you can kind
of aim towards it and and it's key isn't
it to be okay with not uh creating it in
full yeah um but but always aiming
towards always having an ideal to aim
towards but also then shifting
into kind of gratitude for the week that
you ended up having yeah that that as as
life goes it you probably could have had
a worse week you know even though you
didn't go to the gym five times or
whatever it was so um um it's a really
nice mental shft to sort of aim towards
that ideal week and to have the chance
to do that even you know um or to aim
towards an ideal week within the
limitations of someone's life so it
might be that currently you hate your
job but your ideal week would then be um
to be doing some night course in
something else because that's part of
your mission to get out of this job you
hate or whatever that is and so your
idea of the idol week would change as
time went on as well wouldn't it so um
I they kind of keep coming back to it
and um yeah it's nice
um we've got a question from Nisa in our
audience who says when you study your
work for long periods of mind uh sorry
when you study your work for long
periods of time what are some ways in
which you can take care of your mental
health um when you're when you're
studying studying time yeah or working
for a long periods of time okay
um I guess to not do it for long period
of
time to take breaks is kind of obvious
isn't it but but it is the reason people
say it is because it is the right answer
you know that um if if you've got a
stretch and that's what you know that's
why I learned the hard way on when I
began that I was working as if I wasn't
going to do it for a long stretch of
time and it became a long stretch of
time so I realized that wasn't possible
um and now I've made that shift to
having much better balance um and adding
in
other parts of life like you know
socializing or exercising or taking a
break and sleeping and stuff like that
um so you kind of it's It's
acknowledging okay if this is a marathon
what do I need to put in along the way
that's going to ensure I get to the end
of this and for different people that
might be different things um but
generally it includes you know the
basics like social contact good food um
moving your body and sleeping if you can
get those down you're more likely to get
to the end um if you're sacrificing on
any of those it's going to make it much
harder to get to the end so um might
sound like an obvious answer but I think
those those Basics or the things that we
call the basics are the first things we
let slide when we're not doing so good
yeah you know if you got a big project
on well okay I'll just get these four
hours sleep and then I'll crack on and
and I'll do that again tomorrow and um
I'll just grab a takeaway and you know
it's so easy to just um see those things
as uh negotiable I think um so yeah I
think the best thing you can do is
prioritize those and recognize how much
they impact your ability to keep going
and your stamina um so that you can not
do them not do them perfectly but just
keep aiming towards them bit like your
ideal day yeah yeah I really like the
idea of think treating things like
marathons cuz I think you know one one
question I sometimes ask is that
if if the way I lived I lived today was
how I would I live every day how do I
feel about that and if the answer to to
for too many days in a row is like that
would be terrible then I think okay cool
this is this you know it's time for for
a Readjustment and usually for me I find
that a work because it's fun and
energizing it's like oh things are
growing blah blah blah blah blah blah
will then eat into things like exercise
and healthy eating and sleep because
it'll be like 11:00 p.m. and I'll be
like oh but like I'm really excited
about this book that I'm reading let me
just you know and yes I've got an 8 a.m.
breakfast meeting with someone the next
day which I'm also really excited about
but like oh and then so sleep ends up
being the thing that gives yeah and I
think once in a while what but like when
it happens over a long enough enough
period of time it's like uh oh that's
actually you know take care of ourselves
here yeah it just makes a huge
difference doesn't it and something like
sleep the impact is almost instant right
you it's the very next day you will feel
better if you've had more of it so um
it's it's not like um you have to wait a
long time for the results of that so it
is is a great thing to kind of
prioritize if if you notice and it's
probably is one of the first things
we'll look at you know if someone is
returning to therapy for example because
they notice their mood is slipping or
the you know going
downhill you get those Basics back on
track and sometimes that's enough
because they are so powerful you know
they're the reason that you know things
like and your ability to move sleep eat
well and have social connection they're
weapons of war right you know if you got
a prisoner of war the way you break them
is by messing around with those things
so let's not do it voluntarily to
ourselves every day um let's just keep
trying to you know if we've had a few n
nights let's just put an one in there
and see if we can kind of
redirect yeah I find that for me having
like clear rules in place for stuff is
like remarkably helpful like knowing
that Thursday night is is always a date
night or for example knowing that okay I
am not going
to arrange any meetings before like 10:
a.m. or you know thing things like that
where I know that if I actually stuck to
these rules it would almost Force some
kind of balance in my life so that I
don't have to think about it so I think
about it and someone messages me and
it's like oh the Calendar's full but the
only time is like a 7:00 a.m. breakfast
I know in that moment I'll be tempted to
be like hell yeah but I know that when
it comes down to it I'll get five hours
of sleep that night and then that would
not be good yeah in the long in the long
run so
I I like to keep an eye on these Basics
and just think okay like what are the
what are the rules yeah and now that I
have the privilege of having a team uh
and run my own business it's like cool
how do I automate the how do I automate
the adherence to the rules so that I
don't have to think about it yeah like
asking my assistant to be like can you
just make sure the Cal they're always
three gym sessions and while we're there
can we book a personal trainer for them
so that I feel compelled to go and while
we're there can just not have any
meetings after like 11: a.m. oh like
whatever whatever the thing might be
yeah and I think like different people
have different levels of control over
their time and their day but to whatever
extent Possible having rules that force
balance on your life I think you know to
answer this person's question is the way
that you take care of your physical and
mental health while you're working for
long periods of time because to be
honest the 15th hour is both work is
probably going to be not that productive
and I think students in particular get
themselves into this thing of like oh my
God it's so important like you know to
to to to your point around how we
probably don't even remember our gcsc
and a a Lev results anymore cuz no one
really cares but when your student is
like this is like the most
important thing in the world cuz my
whole life is dependent on all these and
yeah yeah and it's interesting that when
you mentioned about kind of that
tendency to like um uh you're you're
feeling tired and you're feeling that
exhaustion but the tendency is to squash
it and ignore it in order to do a little
bit more like if you're studying or
whatever and you got exams and and and
that extra stuff that you did probably
wasn't that productive or helpful
because you were exhausted and not
concentrating and lacked Focus but you
still force yourself to sit in the chair
and and endure being there so that
you've done your I don't know 10 hours
of revision or whatever it is um and so
I think there's a shift towards us kind
of listening to our bodies a bit more
and just acknowledging that tiredness
isn't
pathological it's your body letting you
know it needs something rest and
replenishment or you know fuel or
whatever it is
hydration um and that it's okay to
listen to your body it doesn't mean
you're kind of opting out of hustle
culture or you know you're going to send
your career down the pan it's it's
sustainability and and um the marathon
thing isn't it nice um final question um
a bunch of people in our podcast
Community asked around how like if
someone is if someone else that they
know is if if someone that we know is
struggling with the mental health or
seems to be struggling with the mental
health or seems to be struggling in some
way yeah what are some ways to approach
that situation in a way that's like
tactful and nice and not too like
getting involved in other people's
business if they want to um
I think the the the sort of trap that we
tend to fall into is is often from the
most well-meaning people because we we
desperately don't want to say the wrong
thing so we say nothing yeah and we
maybe even avoid that person right we
try to Grace them with Grace them with
our absence right and say oh just stay
away because they' got a lot going on
and and I'll probably put my foot in it
and say the wrong thing or um and
actually
mostly what people don't need is someone
to come along and solve an unsolvable
problem they need some human connection
and someone to be there and
um and to have their back and be by
their side and show that it matters to
them if they're not okay um but often we
we don't buy into that as helpful we
think we need to step in and solve the
problem um so you know often when people
are saying you know what should I do
what should I say and and it's it's less
about what you do and what you say and
it's more about how you make that person
feel so and not by taking away their
distressed feelings but by adding in a
sense of connection and um letting them
know that someone has their back and
cares for them is hugely supportive so
you know if I'm if I'm working with
someone who is grieving for example you
can't take grief away no one can um you
know magic you out of that um but often
those people will say that the the
friends that they not that they value
the most but that have been most helpful
to them aren't necessarily even the ones
that come along and start talking about
the grief and and opening everything up
they can also be the friends who come
along and say let's go for a dog walk
once a week together and and on that in
that time maybe you discuss the the
latest show you've been watching or um
you know some comedy thing you went to
see or you
know complete distraction from your pain
that's just as valuable if you're that
person right if you're the friend who
doesn't know how to open up those things
and talk about them it's okay to uh talk
about something else and and be you know
sometimes people can be so grateful for
that um but you're still connecting with
that person so you're still saying Good
Times or bad I'm next to you and we'll
walk through it together so um but
equally it's okay to just ask that
person you know how how can I support
you I re it really matters to me if
you're not okay and I want to be here
for you I have no idea how to do that
right so let me know if if I'm getting
it wrong steer me in the right direction
for what you need and I won't take it
personally I'll just take your direction
and then you've already kind of just
named the elephant in the room and and
and your own insecurities about how to
help you know I'm I'm really scared
about saying the wrong thing so let me
know if I if I do that and I will adjust
and and it just takes the fear and out
of the whole situation everyone can name
what it is um and then you can just get
to work with connecting with someone and
and then support comes out of that I
think you don't have to be the therapist
nice I think that's a great place to end
this thank you so much thanks having me
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye